Armory
Armory web weapons whoa
[Music]
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to dead space we're on
another ship we're on the military ship
which means that we have to
um deal with the problems that are on
the military ship uh which
don't trust you sorry buddy
there's no personal is even on this ship
hey what's up buddy how you doing is
that Amro for my big boomy gun
all right
good to know
there's probably a bunch of goodies what
what am I am I okay
is it too hot
uh
Isaac no light fire I take no light fire
I mean fire on a spaceship is probably
the biggest carrying a 12 Megaton
Warhead the crash at the torpedo Bay
heart I need you to handle that nuke
right away before something sent it off
all right
you know I'm not a nuclear engineer
right I don't need you to be just
stabilize the Warhead and eject it away
from the ishimura Christ dammit no one
trained for carve-up Monsters with a
plasma cutter either you haven't let us
down yet uh-huh I haven't let you down
yet
um well that blew up in my hand man this
is not going well for old Isaac here I
have no Health
um is there a store on this shipper am I
just am I just on my own man I did not
prepare for this in any considerable way
but oh well Isaac doesn't need to be
prepared so long as there's not fire I'm
gonna be a-okay
no no no no
uh you also no no hey you had uh
well thank you for that
there's at least some money on here man
are these their sleep pods this is so
depressing I mean honestly
I would sleep here because for some
reason when I was on tour I've talked
about this before being in an enclosed
space on it but on a tour bus you're in
these little coffins just like that
except they're sideways I slept great on
those
hi bud oh
oh no oh no
oh did you uh did you hit a stasis thing
did I hit a stasis thing oh you're still
alive oh my God can you not
I don't know what I'm grabbing okay that
got you
oh good health okay well that's a
problem
the Twitchy fast ones
love that the soldiers must have had
speakers when they were turned those
units merged right into their bodies
changed them they're [__] fast Isaac
stay sharp uh-huh
man that's really specific and
knowledgeable of you
I'm so glad that you uh let me know
about all that and gave me the exact
pertinent information that I needed
how very kind of you
interesting
command officers only
huh
well this don't look very nice
standard procedure
standard procedure man how did all these
soldiers get taken down by one of those
things
I mean I get it getting an ambush but
it's not like they had any of them nosy
thing oh I guess it crashed in
no it would it would crash because they
were out of control and it killed almost
everybody so whatever Eyes Only priority
black CEC vessel USC issue in breach of
Earth gov system isolation order
believed to have recovered marker 3a3
hey
hey oh special ops has confirmed the
system but unable to provide Planet
location
well that's unhelpful exercise Extreme
Caution if marker 3A has been recovered
on board infection is a credible threat
chalk point to Aid is system moved to
position out of local scope range and
await signal from ishimura to confirm
location objective secure marker 3A if
infection is present initiate
sterilization protocol urid dicey well
that sounds fun and Whimsical if
infection is not present initiate
containment product protocol Apollo all
personnel must without exception submit
it to full psychological examination
during debriefing well I guess I didn't
they didn't do the whole uh exercise
Extreme Caution thing because that was
kind of an important part of it it was
kind of an essential part of it if you
ask me kind of like the most important
part of it wait was this always open
hostiles are aliens repeat aliens and
extremely dangerous all Personnel two
arms fired Wills all right well that
didn't help anybody what am I doing with
this
oh hey whoa whoa buddy
is there one behind me I feel like
there's one behind me
oh yeah there was one behind me oh wait
wait that's an infecty dude stop that
whoa whoa you're still alive
oh my God no no no no no no
oh
so use was still alive
that was extremely unhelpful
why did I need that uh energy I I
actually am unsure where let me check my
map which I never do
oh
um
there was a locked door over there did
that need energy
it might have
yeah
why did I do this I don't even know why
I do anything anymore all I know is
Isaac no like fire because that's there
it might be that I needed it uh down no
I've been there down um that elevator
but let me just double check to make
sure that this didn't have like
on energy Port uh does not look to be
the way that that is
it's locked
back we go I'm sure that battery's fine
being chucked around like that
they build them sturdy here in the
future
in the Dead Space world everything oh so
sturdy is everything sideways I guess
that makes sense slightly tilted I'm
gonna bring this downstairs with me
feels like something I might need I
actually don't know who don't even think
about it
don't even think about it you thinking
about it you thinking bro
you thunk a lunker
oh that wait a minute did it just
explode
did it come oh I see well good good
thing I think I have this
that's what that was interesting
very convenient Seize Your Glory Mr
Clark hello I must speak with you hi
Dr Terence kind the issue more is Chief
science officer I studied the marker for
the church I'm done talking to
unitologists
but the planet won't rest until the
marker is returned you can't leave watch
me
yeah watch me I love that response
that is fantastic
radiation Hazard hmm
great oh good wow I'm glad those are
pointing inward
um really fun oh that is a big old
rocket
unstable is it now
where are you where are you
here's a oh my God that was not what I
was expecting
one so no the bluey took a Bluey
who wants the kab Louie
well that's bad
Ah that's what that meant
it was literally saying contain all
explosive material
that is key pertinent information
explodesian in a weapons based bad news
for everybody
let me uh try that again okay I'm
assuming I need to shoot these things
not only will it explode yes it's gonna
nuke everything okay so if I hit him in
the body with one of these it should
separate it pretty easily out of there
but definitely don't
I saw that
all right
power required release okay duly noted
okay easy peasy easy peasy so easy
almost too peasy okay so what do I need
to do here
oh fire bad
that by the fire is totally fine ah this
looks important there was a a
thingamabob here right
ah yes
so not so bad so long as more of those
things don't come around
uh control release release I might have
just nuked someone
probably fine
maybe I could nuke the planet from orbit
I thought I saw an item drop down
a learning Bridge
so am I okay to blow things up now the
warhead's clear damn it this doesn't add
up
if the Valor was just on patrol why
bring a nuke and if they had a Target
what's out here except us yeah I know
I'm downloading a Munitions report right
now I'll clear your route to the engine
room grab that Singularity core and
let's get out of here
even though I just read the note that
explained exactly what that was all
about
hello I know thank you for Handy yeah I
don't know about any of this also I
really hope that in the future when
there are spaceships that humans have
that they are this Sparky like the
electrical systems are just this
unstable
just completely haphazard all over the
place
no hazards all hap
no happiest
save please I like saving
[Music]
Armory is that good for me Armory
Armory web weapons
whoa my God oh God Slow Down slow down
slow down slow down
and then when you burst apart I'm going
to shabboski
that took area
where oh my God oh my God oh my God
[Applause]
oh how are you still alive
holy [__] okay Stacy's don't work on you
oh my God please oh yes please
oh you're still alive
where there's more
I'm out of Health I thought I had some
health
I thought I picked up a bunch of Med
packs but I did not or else I just ate
them all oh that's very helpful thank
you thank you for that
so stasis no good on those
and that's fine
because I'm really good at shooting oh
really oh different explodies Maybe
well I'm not happy that I came in here
shooting range
oh really
oh my God
shooting range online caution live fire
exercise
blue I'm guessing I don't hit
uh
whoop
and it's hard to know where they're
gonna come okay
whoa whoa why why
oh
oh my God
[Applause]
die die please die die die die die die
ow die oh you're not dying
Stomps seem to be largely ineffective
still going I was not paying attention
[Music]
oh my God
is that up baby
holy [__] wait wait wait wait wait wait
whoa
I'm still playing the game
lost some points everybody's okay
baby oh where's baby oh God baby
holy [__]
no oh God I'ma stop you
I need the bullets
damn it damn you you still alive
oh where are you
man I'm really not doing the right
weapon for this
holy [__] I see you back there
[Music]
are you still alive oh it's another one
no it's the same one
damn you God damn you
engaged
shooting range out of service please
contact maintenance
well
that was fun
that was quite not what I expected
that was nuts
what the hell was that about
holy crap I don't know if I got the
right score but uh
that was a damn thing
well I'm alive and that's all that
matters
yippee and I opened all these lockers
which I'm assuming means I got all the
points
I Stomp all the corpses I don't know
oh oops oh God damn it
okay I'm assuming I got everything great
well
wow just in case you never know okay
well that was great that really went
great for me that one's super good and
great
at least they're giving me so much Med I
needed that badly okay how am I doing uh
running low on this ammo time to go back
to Old Reliable
okay
infirmary oh uh is that a present are
you giving that to me bro
is that for me is that for me dude
is that for me wow you shouldn't have
you probably shouldn't have
uh I have a med kit I don't know if
that's gonna help
you want me to
help help you
uh-huh
three teams One mission good
all right
oh and he's gone
oh wow that's that's less than ideal
oh
uh come get me
honestly he's working out pretty nicely
oh it was to show me to slow it I get it
I'm going it's my chance
man this is just so much more effective
who needs bullets
not me okay was there anything over
there that I missed I went through so
quickly I didn't even have a chance to
redeem myself
um I'm gonna assume that there's nothing
and I'm okay
which is a safe assumption to make
always
dead you know that I know my own [__]
corporate [__] come in WoW
Hammond come on bro Hammond my dude
Hammond
you can't do this
you can't do it like this bro
hammondy well what is happening I'm
stuck oh no no not here not now what's
going on Isaac control yourself
Isaac please Isaac please please Isaac
Isaac Isaac get out of there Isaac
let's talk
heart attack
oh my God are you kidding me I really
I oh wow
wow Jesus Christ Isaac why did you do
this
Isaac why did you do this how could you
do that Isaac Isaac how could you do
that
I seek you fool how far is that gonna
send me back
infirmary okay just before the infirmary
great all right well that's good enough
for me
slice and dice
slice and dice oh come on give me the
Gap I'll take that nope I'll take that
nope I'll just get it on the way then
okay you got it you got it pal oh okay
just run into it that's fine with me
look I'm not gonna complain
the only thing I'm gonna complain about
is getting stuck on this again
okay not getting stuck
all right
what do we have here
goodies goodies goodies goodies good
ease great ease actually
goodies no nodes no nodes no nodes got
your nodes
no nose
radiation Hazard huh good thing I got a
suit that's probably protected against
that
probably
all right let's save it
uh
how hazardous you all right buddy you
hang in there
you're so tough
so tough
cargo bay
uh
wow
I got a bad feeling about this space
oh it's the Pod oh wow
all right
that really got him
I really got him like straight up got
him got him quick and good damn they
were not ready for that
hmm they're not like me
not tough as Nails not ready for this
seize the glory I don't know what Glory
you want me to seize but um
I don't think there's much glory to be
seized here I hope this explodes it's
got red glowy on it I'm assuming it
explodes
do the long spooky hallway
oh I dropped it right at the wrong time
whoa no thank you nada
who else
whoa I hear you
why did that not
foreign
so they got armored pieces on them I
think
is the tricky bits
oh and you stomp them and they stasis
where
oh my God oh my God holy crap
oh my God that was the unexpected
did I get you
that was a lot easier than I was
thinking it would be
caught him at the wrong time
okay
well that was tumultuous
but I'm alive
I wish the big guy squished when I
stomped on him
huh
Good Golly
okay
it wasn't just a nuke they came loaded
for war so you can destroy
this was no Patrol they knew about the
issue more someone knew we were all dead
from the moment we arrived uh-huh
yep makes sense but not me though I'm uh
I'm I'm gonna live I promised uh Nicole
that I would live and we would live
happily ever after together uh once we
get off the ship so um
you uh you don't know us at all
just checking behind things
in case we got hidey holes
nope somehow I'm doing all right on
supplies I don't know how I'm doing on
ammo uh running a bit low I've got
plenty of force ammo though so that'll
help and two rubies
two big beautiful rubies
thank you 100 credits
guess I don't pay the soldiers very much
no eyes ignore like fire
oh no
I know like fire what
oh it would be so convenient wow is this
a v
18 engine
very impressive
I like saving I hate fire all right fire
I wonder if I just run blindly through
in one straight shot how I'll make it
yeah
no no
yeah all right Isaac wait a minute
oh hey I didn't mean to use a health
pack
oh no like fire
okay
and this helped me here too bad I can't
Crouch
oh man that's it
do I have another
everything anything else here
fire extinguisher perfect
get extinguished
you'd think that would do something you
you really think that would do something
um
but it didn't is there another one over
here
I didn't time that oh my God
ah just what I needed
my good engine's good and it's great
engines actually
okay well that's not quite I think if I
stack them on top of each other well or
if I hold it
perfect easy thank you node
and Locker perfect
okay I don't know I don't know if I'm
gonna need these
hot as hell
um
there's something down there that's
important
just goodies money
I too keep all of my money in a locker
against a wall
can I have it
there
hold this right
he's right there
okay what do we have here circuit
breaker
oh fire suppression yes please and
elevators wow you have enough power for
everything that never happens
bad oh
whoa you jumpy
why are you jumpy
oh you got roast
ing for you
whoa is that a gold or a ruby did it
just give me a ruby
in your roomie
oh well I didn't even have to wait
I didn't even have to do that strange
box thing I could have just turned the
fire suppression on well
live and learn
then kill some dead things
save again
saving
okay elevator go upbeat
this uh this trip for a singularity core
has really been
um not what I was expecting
in the funnest way
so fun
good
nice engine though
elevated upper decks is locked
always of course am I the biohazard oh
hi another malfunction atheists in the
red someone get the door open
all right
[Music]
no wait no wait
well um
that
how did he get in here
how did oh okay I guess I didn't I don't
know
okay a singularity chord
rerouting power to what
all right I'm out of here good thing the
thing's tiny Hamming vital they just
flatlined he was gone
oh my God
I'm I'm going I think
I've always been taught to use elevators
during fires and explodies
it is strange that spaceships don't have
stairs
evacuate how immediately extremely
immediately wow time for a snack break
oh no time
what are you doing what are you doing
stop stop drop whoa I'm going I'm gone
I'm gone I'm gone I'm gone I'm Gone
the sucker up bro whim Fam thank you who
am I'm going I'm still
going I'm just going oh my God I'm just
going I'm just going
oh yeah Survivor wait Barracks no no not
what I need
heat exchange wait not that way where
did that guy go why is that locked
why is that locked oh I should have gone
that way oh oh no
oh I'm gonna die
uh-huh
how are you gonna exchange your heat
oh no no no
you're gonna okay it was gonna it's time
delay yeah
uh-huh
oh
that critical huh
oh so close
move
ouch
[Music]
oh I'm in here
oh well that's awfully convenient
that worked out quite nicely huh
Isaac come in I'm here [__] that was
close
ten Johnson now Hammond and I'm tracking
movement from The Valor I think some of
those mutated Soldiers made it on board
what about the Valor Singularity Corps
it's covered in blood what a goddess
God I hope Emma was right about that
shuttle he said it was on the crew deck
along with every unitologist on the ship
and their marker you'll need to wait
someone's opened the door near the
bridge atrium
it'll get you to the crew deck but who's
left with that kind of clearance
Isaac something's up but we have to get
that shuttle for God's sake be careful
we're all that's left
we're all that's left except for Nicole
you're figuring about Nicole can't
forget about Nicole uh
but unfortunately
It's the End of Days
which means that it's the end of this
episode
what an adventure on that ship it was
quite an adventure but thank you
everybody so much for watching now we
get to meet all the unitologists
hopefully with a stop at a store first
uh which means that we actually get to
stock up on supplies that we need um but
you know you know give or take oh how
far who knows what's gonna happen so
thank you and as always I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye